with my colleague Kirk on Hauser at
University of Alberta have been
proposing with 14 13 other members a
program taught right to life which is
the evolution of life based on photo
sentence how did you come to be that an
organism figured out how to use the
light from the Sun to make chemical
bonds that could be human that's the
essence of what there's Bob knows we
don't understand the evolution of this
process photosynthesis was a major
driver and it was all microbial and how
it came to be to them and so that's what
we're trying to do taking these
molecules are not worrying about the
sequences looking at the structures and
see if we can find them Legos that were
the original Legos and that was added on
and what was added on at the battle to
get it on it problem is to be very very
interdisciplinary so we have physical
chemistry and molecular biologists
within peel chemistry of geologists
structural biologists c4 allows us to
have a very very broad group that can
interact and potentially then peel off
into smaller groups that can generate
funds for physical research and
laboratories or interfere we had an
understanding of how photosynthesis
evolved we could potentially use that to
derive molecules that could split water
without biology so there's a natural
economy based on electrons and there's a
human economy based on money and what I
want to do is try to couple them better
so that the human economy can be based
upon the natural economy of solar energy
stood in water was going to be an
optimum problem
[Music]